and here we are once again let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up y'all voice is a little
scratchy today but whatever you know you
can't win them all every week
um today Big Show I got movie and TV
reviews
NBA playoffs still
[Music]
uh just so much you know what I mean
comments some of my favorite Instagram
stuff uh shows I'm gonna be doing so hey
guys welcome back
history
[Music]
all right the the roofing with Griffin
uh
intro was slow today uh I don't know why
I have a voice of scratchy I didn't
drink enough water this morning but
anyways welcome to riffing with Griffin
uh I appreciate you guys uh being here
as always so make sure you hit the
subscribe
you know what I mean hit that subscribe
button y'all uh uh it's you know just
hit this you know what to do hit the
Subscribe you guys know Eric Griffin
gaming I like the game I'm trying to
grow my gaming channel but you know 30
something thousand followers but I can
only get like 100 people to watch at a
time where is everybody I don't know so
come check me out on there support me
any way you want you can be a subscriber
there you could be a member on YouTube
you could be a patreon member
um yeah here we go upcoming shows
you know I got I got some upcoming shows
coming up uh this week y'all I I never I
don't know if I say it right because
somebody already sent me a comment about
it like say the name right but I think
it's Louisville Louisville I don't know
how to say it but you know I'm gonna be
at the Louisville Comedy Club this
weekend so come check me out there uh
okay so you know there you go you can go
check me these are some of the dates I
have coming up and some others are being
added uh so I was just at the Blue Room
in in uh Springfield great Saturday
night two sold out shows there Saturday
night Thursday and Friday or weren't as
big but it was still great so anyway
Louisville Comedy Club April 20th
tomorrow April 20th through the 29th I'm
sorry 29th through the 22nd and then
next week I'm gonna be at the mothership
in Austin April 28th through the 30th
and then I got some stuff coming up in
June some May dates are coming but I
just don't have those on uh my site yet
so come check me out there man
come check me out okay so uh let's get
into some comments uh um some people
but you know anytime you want to comment
you know this on Instagram but the
comments on the YouTube page you know
from all different types of episodes I
just go to this little comment thing on
YouTube and it's it's pretty cool
somebody Scott Clark from somebody
watched by the Steve Lee and I talking
doing movie reviews from a long time ago
the guy said Stevie is spot on the Joker
is a real one when you've lived around
people like that or lived through it
yourself and you see Joker's pain it's
real pain he did an amazing job so that
guy really
Steve Scott's Clark Clark
went way back on that one
uh Ivan SM oh [__] man when I watched
Workaholics Griffin was one of my
favorite characters pure talent now I'm
glad that there is so much content where
he is because I feel like every content
that he's in he's just hilarious thank
you Ivan oh my God
uh let's see bullets Michael with a
terrible comment love you love you
brother Potato Head
Potato Head it's so stupid stupid Bobby
now that's I'm gonna have that forever
um somebody was a lot of girls now are
watching the Matt Rife episode I'm gonna
have Matt on again but uh so Iris uh
Carrillo why are you trying to press
mommy issues to him like damn he just
wants someone with life experience
it's back you said this thing about
older women but anyway
um let's see let's see okay Coach Steve
money the games and this is when he's
he's talking about last of us the games
creators said of the game testers that
50 of the non-parents said they would
have let Eli die Ellie die but a hundred
percent of parents said they would have
not interesting statistic I I don't know
if that's true or not Matthew did Jesus
DeJesus Rob Lowe show his pretentious
trash and I like Rob Lowe beef is the
truth and I don't care for her stand up
but she's a good on beef okay well I
shouldn't even read that part but
whatever
uh Matthew oh he also said secession is
the best show in years
um anyways so you know if you uh want to
send a comment I will read your comments
and so uh thanks for being live too or
for the people that are watching me live
right now so please share man you know
what I mean y'all gotta share and uh you
know let people know about we're from
with Griffin if you like it you know
what I mean you people that like working
with Griffin you gotta spread the word
you got to help me build the show I know
I'm on 200 something episodes but I like
my little show if you've never been here
before I talk about everything and
anything and everything sometimes I'm
hilarious sometimes I'm introspective
sometimes I'm serious but I'm 100
authentic authentically me so thanks for
being here uh if you're a new person
that's what you could look to expect if
you're people if you've been here all
the time thank you I appreciate your
continued support
okay so let's get into it let's see
what's going on
um you know I've talked about this
before but you know you guys should see
how messy my office is Rachel and I are
messy
man we're messy and like she it's like
Rachel's just as she's like talk about
zero [__] okay about stuff
like there's a box of crackers
that's on like this
table in in our living room like the the
counter table and we like to eat on we
don't really have like a kitchen table
it's weird right so we had I had this
little like table there like it folds up
so we eat on that in the living room
because it's just her and I right
there's a box of crackers that have been
sitting there that anybody else would be
like okay this goes in the kitchen
Rachel sees it every day she don't even
care
part of me is I just leave it there
because I'm like I wonder if there's
anything in her to be like oh these
crackers should probably be in the
kitchen nothing
yeah
I'm a lead up crackers there
I'm gonna leave them there and I'm gonna
see how long I'm gonna give you give you
an update we're gonna have a cracker
update
to see how many weeks those crackers are
gonna stay right there
dishes like I do the dishes and I don't
even like doing the dishes so there'll
be dishes in the sink like
like I'm about to go out of town so when
I go out of town for sure I take the
trash out and do the dishes because if I
don't do the dishes if I don't take the
trash out when I come back it's gonna be
like piles of trash around the trash
thing because she just and I don't know
I think that's why it works I think it's
like that's part of our compatibility is
just really not
it's not a you know it's not a big deal
you know what I mean
so I don't know I don't know I'm just
curious to see where you guys are so in
the comments or like even right now live
the people that are watching live are
you the messy one or the clean one in
your relationship or are you both the
same like a unique freaks are you both
messy or is one messy and one clean and
I'd love to know how that works because
to me I don't think that can work if you
got a neat freak and a messy person
together that just doesn't I I can't see
that working to me it just seems like a
lot of fighting and it's a lot of
compromise that you don't want to do you
know what I mean so
I'm curious just to see where you guys
are with that
okay
um last week I'll be uh you know I keep
I could be forgetting stuff and I don't
want to forget stuff that I want to talk
about this week you know what I mean so
let's not forget anything about this
week let's go let's let me just go right
into some right into some of these funny
Instagram stories
first of all okay there's this dude on
Instagram
um I love this kid
his name is his name is
waxing22 I think that's his name you
know I mean I think that's his name
waxing 22 but this dude is my spirit
animal man
so go get this guy a follow I love this
dude
this video has no purpose I just gotta
show off my fine ass oh my gosh
man I'm blessed with a beautiful mother
and a handsome father and you know what
they made a sexy young man what y'all
know man yo what's up everybody this
video has no purpose
oh my God that dude that dude is a trip
so it's like waxing underscore 22 he's
like huge on on Tick Tock he just like
every time I was watching he's just got
this like really great energy and this
like incredible confidence you know what
I mean and so I don't know I think
people make fun of him but at the same
time I think he just rolls with him he
just doesn't care you know what I mean
so I love that kid
um what's another uh so some weird
Instagram stories I saw is uh every
blue-eyed person is a descendant of one
single human
that's crazy
this is you know
on my one of my favorite Instagram
websites is puberty
uh they yeah every single every
blue-eyed person is a descendant of one
single human that's crazy and it says
the the person lived more than six
thousand years ago and carried a genetic
mutation that has now spread across the
world
I mean a genetic mutation so if you've
got blue eyes you all are related that's
nasty
just
weird Instagram story
uh
all right so this was a good one too I
really liked I don't know if I I don't
know if I have this set up right where
you can really see it good let me see
uh uh let's see this was a great little
Instagram feed it was like overthinking
is the biggest cause of unhappiness it
took me nine years to beat overthinking
here are eight ways you could beat
overthinking and I thought these were
some some really cool
this is a really cool thing oh oops
sorry let's go back here it is oh here
we go boom
oh you can't see it that well but I'll
just read it the problem is really the
problem 99 of harm is caused in your
head by you and your thoughts
um
I mean that's so true man you just be
thinking oh and guys thanks for the
super chats uh
uh you know I'll get to your thing in a
second here and thanks for that Joe Hill
you know he just asked like but what do
I what how was I working with Adam
Sandler uh I'll talk about it in a
little bit maybe you know and thank you
jr1n thanks for the Super Chat you guys
agree if you want to support me that way
too it's a great way to support me too I
appreciate that so yeah I think when you
overthink things are in your head man
avoid self-rejection don't think you
deserve you don't think you deserve that
opportunity apply for it anyway yeah
it's like stop like making yourself feel
like you're not good enough I think
that's great I think self-esteem that's
connected to you know have some
self-esteem it's like those are the
things that hold us back right silence
in time the truth is most problems
aren't solved with more thinking they're
solved with less oh so true like give
yourself a beat like give yourself some
time in a moment to just like like
really like like not think about it you
know just turn your brain off I think
that's meditation and or doing something
that you love to do or just find
something mindless that you could just
because then when you go back to it
you'll be like oh man you know it just
wasn't as serious as I thought I always
think that's great in relationships when
you're having a fight with somebody like
when I when Rachel and I we first
started we we get into these fights man
I would just leave I had to go on a walk
I would go on a walk you know then and
then you know she would hit me up and
then you know or then it would be fine
you know that's one thing I gotta say I
love about Rachel is she is like she
don't hold on to things and it is so
hard to be mad at her that's how I knew
she was the one like like even when
we're mad she could just she got a way
that can like take away all of my anger
like this just with a smile with a hug
with a little joke and I think that
that's about this you know uh
when you start criticizing yourself for
past mistakes or seeing disaster around
every corner is there anything I could
do right now to change the password to
positive influence the future if the
answer is yes do it take action huh
that's an interesting one The Power of
Now you're not going to over overthink
your way to be to a better future you're
not going to overthink your way to a
better past
oh that's just being present right be
present fact check your own thoughts uh
your thoughts will create scenarios in
your mind oh exactly like that's just
about overthinking too you know it's
like when you you know you fact check
yourself make sure you're not
saying something that didn't happen or
you know I mean you create things in
your head and you realize oh that really
didn't happen that happens in fights all
the time how many times you fighting
with somebody and then you go you know
you say you know you said this or this
happened and then later you think about
it you go you know what it probably
didn't happen that happened that way so
that's important
yeah
uh acceptance is peace yeah I agree with
that accept things Health starts in your
mind I mean you know so that's a great
this was a great uh these are some of
some great Instagram posts that I that I
liked this week yeah there's the
blue-eyed one there's my dude waxing
yeah so you know I had some good
um Instagram posts this week man that
was the one from some of them from last
week so anyways all right so I got to
the Instagram post boom we got to the
comments boom
um all right let's just get to like uh
um
so the NBA playoffs are going on man uh
I'm not gonna I'm gonna go into it in
depth is what I did last week but man
NBA playoffs is so good I actually can't
believe how great these first round
series are in the West
uh I think the East has the top three
teams but the West these playoffs are
crazy this Clippers Sun's first round
matchup that could be a Western
Conference Finals like their team the
way the teams are stacked I wish Paul
George was playing man because it really
would uh
it really like it really would be a much
better matchup and you know when
someone's out when a major player is out
you always think in your mind ah man
this this isn't what we really this
isn't the best version of the series but
it's a great series Sun's won game two
they still Clippers still look great I
think this is good this is gonna go
seven and I think my clippers are gonna
win
um they suspended Draymond Green and
that's another great series Sacramento
Golden State Warriors the defending
Champions versus the number three seed
all year long
you know they suspended Draymond Green
for like you know stepping on this guy
I've seen the place so many times I'm
watching a lot of sports shows you know
I've seen uh this uh this Draymond Green
stomp let me see if I can find it on you
know
um
you know he steps on sabonis and sabonis
you know
pulls his leg you know what I mean holds
his leg and then him getting away he's
and did he did he demonstratively step
on him yeah probably but it's like yo
man you pulling my leg in the game like
get off me I don't think he should have
been I don't I think he should have been
ejected I think the other guy should
have been ejected too uh and then in in
the aftermath they suspended him because
of the excessiveness of it and then his
history I think this is a terrible
mistake I think they're ruining the
playoffs with this these are the
defending Champions We want to see them
play it's like find the guy you know
find him a million dollars or something
but let the guy play I think that was a
mistake it was it was a real mistake and
I don't know who they doing this for
especially to not suspend the guy that
instigated the whole thing and the game
before the same guy held him in another
instance held him and then the other guy
held his leg too I mean they like goaded
him into like a big demonstrative
response so he could get kicked out
maybe and he did so I don't know I I
think that I'm not a big fan of Draymond
Green either I don't even like I don't
like him at all in terms of like his
game I don't like his game I don't like
his attitude I just it's not for me not
to say that he's not great or whatever
but it's like I just don't it's not my
cup of tea you know what I mean so
whatever with that and then like the
Eastern Conference is kind of boring
right now these playoffs are born I
don't think they're going to get good
till the end but the West man the first
round this is probably the best first
round in the NBA Playoffs that that's
been around that that's going on for our
since a long time man so you know keep
checking that out and even Denver
Denver's Trucking along people are
sleeping on them and they're the number
one seed so NBA playoffs have been uh
pretty pretty exciting so you know just
check that out all right check that
out check it out
so I haven't seen John Wick 4 yet
okay I haven't seen John Wick for
um
have you guys if if anybody's seen it
you know let me know you know if I mean
you know wait wait let me do this
um how do you do this again I don't know
how to do this wait how do you I'm
trying to
I don't know wait what's going on here
I'm trying to just every time I do this
by myself it's like it's you know what I
mean
it's like okay here we go open image in
new tab all right
oh why is it so little man it's just
always something to see I'm trying to do
this so I could show you guys you know
just to have it on the screen but look
how little that image is
anyways I haven't seen I haven't seen
John Wick 4 yet but I'm probably gonna
see it this weekend when I'm out in uh
I'm out in Louisville
but in anticipation of watching John
Wick four I watched John Wick one two
and three man this dude kills a lot of
people you know what I mean this guy
this dude this dude
like he must kill like 300 people in
every movie you know and so like if you
if you're one of these people that's
like oh violence is terrible and all
this kind of stuff and it's like it is
what it is right but it's it's so much
like I often think like where are they
getting all these henchmen from and like
how can they replenish them so anyways I
just want to recap John Wick one two and
three real quick because it was just
like very fascinating to me like these
are actually great movies like and there
it's a great story
following this guy through all these
movies like Keanu Reeves
when he was Neo except for this last one
which was hot garbage this new Matrix
that came out
hot garbage anyway forget it
but there's something that's great about
him that you could follow him throughout
stories and root for him no matter what
kind of character he's playing there's
something he's got that thing man only
few people in history have that thing he
got that thing it's just something
endearing about him no matter what so I
don't know if you know what what the for
if you've never seen John 1 2 and 3 John
week one two and three spoiler alert
okay so John Wick won so John Wick one
John Wick is a hit man all right he is a
hit man that works for this sort of
Illuminati organization called the high
table so they're like
I don't actually know what they do but
apparently they're like it's like a
League of Assassins and power power
Brokers you know what I mean you kind of
don't get a sense of
who they really are or what they really
do but he somehow got out
okay he got out of the game you don't
normally get out of the game he gets
married he's living a great life after
all the killing and destruction he's
done his wife tragically dies of some
sort of disease they don't really say
okay so his wife dies
after his wife dies she knew she was
gonna die she sends him a dog
to like so he could still love something
all right now cut to he got a great car
a 66 Mustang I believe it is
he out getting gas and some sort of
Russian Yugoslavian whatever sort of
gangsters see him and they're like yo
how much for the car and he's like it's
not for sale
so they somehow follow him
and they break into his house beat him
up and kill his dog
so then John Wick is like okay so I'm
trying to retire my wife is dead and you
gonna kill the thing that reminds me of
my wife that's keeping me grounded
people Gotta Die
so and then this dude who did this is
the son of a of a mobster
and then when the mobster finds out who
he stole this car from
the dad is furious because now he knows
because he's actually worked with John
Wick before he knows this dude is coming
for his kid so he is furious with his
son because now it's like this dude's
gonna kill you dummy so now I gotta try
to kill him before he kills you and me
because of your dumb ass decisions
now John Wick starts it up so they sent
a hit team to John Wick's house of
course he kill all them
all of them right
so then this is what John Wick does a
lot people call him the guy calls him
John can we talk he just hangs up you
know what I mean he's like nah dude we
ain't talking your kid like with that
hang up he says you killed my dog you
stole my car and you sent a hit team
after me bro it's on so then the rest of
the movie is John Wick trying to
find this guy's son to kill him and
obviously he eventually kills him the
father and everybody in this guy's
organization
so you're like okay
that's John Wick one and you're like
damn so then shortly after he gets a new
dog and this is John Wick too he get a
new dog all right so then this guy who
is a part of the high table so he's like
a uppity up he wants to have a seat at
the high table his sister has a seat at
the high table so this is the guy he
John Wick owes him a favor he owes him
something okay because apparently John
Wick to get out of this business he had
to do something for this guy right and
so now John Wick was out so this guy has
a marker on him being like yo
I have this you have to do this that's
part of their their code
so the guy wants John Wick to kill his
sister okay so because if he kills the
sister he then will get a seat at the
high table and be super powerful
so John Wick has to do it he's a man of
honor and code and he knows if he does
this that he could be completely done
with this business and he is out out out
of course John Wick sets it up okay so
then the guy he first says no and then
the guy goes blows up John Wick's house
so he has to do this you know what I
mean he blows up the dude's house you
know what I mean with a hit team and all
this thing the guy's like you gotta go
do this all right so then John Wick goes
he kills his sister
all kills all her men right
and then the brother decides oh okay
well now we got to kill John Wick you
know because he's like I gotta Loose
Ends so then now John Wick is like bro
you made me
kill your sister
I'm out you know who I am
and then the guy calls him he's like yo
John what kind of man would I be if I
didn't you know honor my sister and by
killing his Johnny hangs up on him and
you know what that means if I hang up on
you I'm Coming For You Homie so then
that's the rest of that movie is John
Wick trying to kill this dude
so then there's this place called the
Continental it's like a hotel that the
Hitman it's a part of their their their
thing and if you're on Continental
grounds if you're in this hotel no
business can be conducted so no D and
then if you do you will be excommunicado
you will be like you know everybody's
after you and of course the you know he
has this big chase scene he finds the
brother the brother escapes to the
continental and then John Wick's in
there with him and then the dude's like
John Just Let It Go Walk Away the
manager is like walk away dude John was
like no I can't walk away you know he
said all in his mind and he shoots the
brother in there now all the Hitman are
after him now they put like this bounty
on him so now every Hitman in the whole
world is after John Wick right
I mean it's crazy you know what I mean
so the whole movie of John Wick 2 is him
fighting and trying to escape
and he like is fighting for his life
this whole movie at the end of the movie
he is like with his dog in New York and
he's limping because he just been fought
his ass off and he's like limping
limping limping and you know and then
that movie ends and then John Wick 3
starts and he's limping and limping this
John week three starts like this he
limping and then he fights the dude he
from the beginning of the movie he now
fighting for another two and a half
hours it's crazy like it's crazy he's
killing every Hitman coming his way
right and now he's trying to get to like
the leaders of the high table he's
trying to find them and be like Yo dude
like can you like not kill me right so
he has to kill all his weight and then
he meets up with Halle Berry
if you've never watched John Wick 3 I'm
telling you there is a sequence where
Holly Berry and John Wick are trying to
like they're going to go talk to this
high table Hitman guy
and to convince them to tell him we're
like the leader of the high table is
right and this guy's like now I ain't
gonna do it and then he shoots her dog
and she's like uh oh and then John
Wick's like oh no don't don't you know
it's like a 20-minute kill Fest of of
John Wick and Halle Berry's character
trying to escape this compound
it is some of the most intense graphic
kung fu martial arts gun play scene in a
movie ever
you know what I mean
it's crazy and by the way if you if
you're worried about I'm ruining John
Wick one two and three for you look at
my face go [__] yourself these movies
have been out for five years you know
what I mean like if you haven't seen
them that's on you so anyways so John so
then like all right so he escapes all
that
then he gets to the desert and I don't
know why this these people out in the
desert are the ones in charge
so John Wick's given a task now of he
gotta go kill one of his good friends
and then he can be let he could be hit
he he can be brought back into the fold
you know he decides not to do it then
they team up but then in the end the
dude turns on him I mean it's just and
now I'm just wondering what's going to
happen to John Wick 4 because once again
his life is on the line so I can't wait
to watch John Wick 4. so guys I'm gonna
watch John Wick for this weekend and I
will be back with my review
I love recapping movies because it's
like it's so fascinating but John Wick
might have killed a thousand people in
one two and three like no joke
is that is that exact maybe that's an
exaggeration
but he kills at least
150 people a movie right
so we talk about a good four five
hundred
like it's on peacock right now you can
watch them all on peacock
I mean
he kills a minimum minimum 300 right
it's got to be a minimum 300. even if we
say it's fit like it's crazy so by the
time John wake 4 ends I'm sure it might
be up to like 700 right
where are they getting all these
henchmen
I mean at a certain point like when they
having interviews
somebody's got to be like so why you
need more men what's going on
they're like yeah we need some positions
filled
what happened well you know
John Wick you know it's like what
I is there Dental in this [__] you know
what I mean I I just I don't know
it's crazy
anyways
it's just I can't wait to see John
Wickford that's why I was talking about
this all right guys I want to talk about
I didn't talk about it last week uh but
I want to talk about it this week man
um I was in a movie
and I've talked about this movie or some
experiences I've had but I it's called
Somewhere in Queens starring Ray Romano
uh Ray Romano uh he starred directed he
wrote it started it and directed it and
the last week I went to a soft La
Premiere a screening of the movie and
and Ray was there and a bunch of the
stars were there the stars are Ray
Romano and Lori Metcalf Sebastian's in
it Sebastian maniscalco's in it uh some
great young actors are in it man I gotta
tell you
this is really a great movie
you know and I'm not just saying it
because I'm in it because I had a very
small part in it uh but it it was I when
I watched it I was like oh this is great
it's it's a great family film uh you
know and it's just a really modern sort
of modern story that is a story that has
been told forever and ever of just like
the struggles of fathers and Son the
Father and Son relationship and how it
carries on to when that when you you
were now a son and you become a father
and you have your own demons and it's
just a great story of of a man like
trying to uh you know come to grips with
you know
what kind of father he is with his kid
if he's being selfish if he's living
through his kid so his kid is a
basketball player and you know and he's
living through his kid and it's sort of
like Loosely based on Rey's own story
because his son played basketball and
you know and it's like this story of uh
you know of redemption really of like
um learning you know just learning how
to deal with the issues that happen in
fan in in a family man where you see
that you see a it's a flawed family they
don't necessarily get along they don't
like to talk about issues and and how
the issues fester and you know it's like
you know being in a long marriage and
and how do you keep the keep the spark
even when you're going through something
and and then like you know making
choices as a dad that you think you're
making that are good choices uh you know
you like you think you're doing what's
best for your kid but turns out you're
just doing it for yourself and
you know it's about this this really
great Italian family and and their
struggles of you know what I mean and
it's just it's oh man I I'm not even
doing it justice but it's it's a really
great it's a really great movie uh you
know it's a really good throwback movie
it's not a superhero movie it's not a
you know it's not a
a a crazy wacky comedy either it's just
a great story you're gonna cry You're
gonna laugh and and Ray Romano is just
perfect in this you know uh he's a
really great actor like I didn't even
realize he was this great of an actor
you know because you really follow him
through the story and you know the the
laughs come at times that you don't
think oh I don't know if you're supposed
to laugh at that time but you really
relate like you're gonna really relate
to these people and there's going to be
someone in this family or that you'll be
like oh that's me uh everyone's great in
it Laurie Metcalf is just fantastic if
you don't know who that is she is uh
Sadie Stanley this young actress Disney
star that's turning into just a she is
phenomenal in this shout out to Sadie
there's this new kid
there's this new kid that is uh in the
in the movie where where what's what's
his name again
um Jacob Ward plays his son brand new
actor he is fantastic in this you know
because it's like you know it's about
like this Italian this old school
Italian family and they don't know how
to deal with like issues they don't deal
with the way say you normally deal with
things like now where people say Hey you
go go talk to someone about this or let
no they're the kind of people like ah we
can handle this ourselves you don't need
to go talk to anybody that kind of
attitude but so Jacob Wars his
basketball player and he's he's got he
he needs he doesn't have great
confidence you know so he gets this
girlfriend and then like the
relationship you know yeah I'm not gonna
tell you what happens but it's just like
it's just about all of that man and it
wraps up really nicely and it's I'm
telling you it's like a sweet story that
you're gonna love to watch like it's
it's a great watch and and like when
you're in the theater watching it you
know you feel like you went through
something with all these people you know
you're watching it and you're just like
oh you're laughing and crying there's a
good two or three cry moments in this
that I thought oh this is great uh you
know especially if you're like you know
if you have a relationship with your
father whether even if it's good or bad
because that's me like anytime I watch
something when it's like mother son
stuff that always gets me
so anyways I just want to give a shout
out to Ray Romano
um this was a great movie and I hope he
continues to get into do more directing
because it was a really great movie so
check that out
um beef man let's talk about beef
right uh this this is a great show okay
listen this is a weird
show but I freaking love it
uh beef it's starving it's starring
Steven Yoon and Ali Wong and Joseph Lee
um man
you know beef is uh two people let a
road rage incident
uh burrow burrow into their heads and
slowly consume their every thought and
action
yeah that's a weird description of it
but that's also a great description of
it uh yeah this this this uh freaking
show
you know
Ali Wong and Steve they they have this
incident where like you know someone's
honking at someone and he chases her
down and then their lives start getting
intertwined and this and the show is so
bizarre
because you're following each of these
flawed human beings and what's going on
in their lives
one you would think is like super
successful and the things that she's got
going in her marriage and her kid and
but then you could see like the weird
relationships that's going on in her
life and has what she's trying to do and
and you can see the the unhappiness
right
and then this other guy who is not doing
as well got a criminal cousin uh you
know he's he's got a struggling business
and but he's just he's trying to please
his parents who are back in Korea he's
trying to bring them here and you can
see his life and how it's it and then
how they've now infected each other and
they're obsessed with each other in a in
the most terrible way uh and it but it's
just a fascinating watch I started
watching it and I I'm I'm almost in two
days now I have two more episodes and
I'll be done but this it's a great show
man and and they are doing like acting
wise they are I can't wait to see Ali at
The Comedy Store I haven't seen her
since I started watching this but at the
moment I see her I'm gonna let her know
this was it's a really great show you
know it's a really great show and I I'm
I can't wait to see where it goes I hope
there's not one of these like one C and
things and then they cancel it but man
it's just you know
I'm gonna tell you how good the show is
okay because and even though I'm what
I'm about to say is contradictory to the
point I'm making but I'm just doing a
meta I'm looking at it in an overall
view that's why in on the podcast
because this is how I discuss things
but this is an example of the the
pendulum switching in the world changing
a little bit because this is a
predominantly Asian most of the actors
in this show or agent and it doesn't
matter not that it ever should matter
but what I'm saying is
they have found they're doing such a
great job the story is so great the the
the the shout out to Jake uh the the
director and one of the producers he
actually he actually was a director on
many episodes of um
uh uh I'm dying up here so I've seen he
came to The Comedy Store with Ali one
time and I saw him and I was like oh you
guys are working together that's great
anyways
you really get lost in it and and I
caught myself because I'm a comic and I
just sometimes I'm in my head so I can
like get an overview and be like oh you
know what I'm not even thinking about
that even though I am now thinking about
it but I'm only thinking about it to
talk about it because of how the world
has been in the past like five years you
know how this like push for diversity
inclusion and all this stuff and it
makes you aware of it and so then you
kind of like be like oh I know why
they're doing this type of thing this
show is like the pendulum is now
swinging towards where it's like we're
not thinking about it this is about our
this show is an example of what I like
to talk about Artistic integrity this
show has a lot of Artistic integrity and
the people in the show are great and so
regardless of whatever they are you can
watch it and just be like oh I can
relate to this guy regardless of his age
race
our nationality or whatever because it's
a human story you know it's a human
story and I appreciate this story uh I
just appreciate like how how dark it is
and how like you know you know you watch
them make doing these things and you go
oh man would I do that have I felt like
that and then
you see the depression and pain that
they're going through as characters and
and how they're trying to get over the
hump and then something else happens and
it's just like how they deal with it and
they're making terrible choices and I
love it
so
beef
great show
highly recommend it it's getting sevens
that's probably like eight or nine
really but my point is I really enjoy
the show so if you haven't watched it
make sure you check it out I it's a good
show good ass show
um all right guys okay so some more uh
yeah well wow time is flying today yeah
I'm just I'm just Yip yapping I don't
even feel like I
I don't even feel like I talked about
everything that I wanted to talk about
but whatever it is what it is that's
what I like doing the show all right
some news and notes uh of some nonsense
that's going on in fat news I haven't
done fat news in a while but oh that's
not the right one here we go in fat news
McDonald's is changing its burger recipe
finally
it's like what dude McDonald's
who you think you are man you're
changing your burger recipe like that's
no one cares
you think people are gonna there's gonna
be a long line outside the McDonald's
like oh yo you hear what McDonald's is
doing they change that burger recipe
like nobody like dude your burger recipe
could be hot garbage and people are
still going to go to McDonald's it's
like an institution in our head now it's
over billions of people served like even
when you don't want McDonald's you go
get McDonald's you know sometimes you're
just like oh man McDonald's is like good
for like a Fast breakfast McDonald's is
like you know it's late and you're like
ah there's nothing open um let me go to
McDonald's it's just like the name you
know
you know what I mean so they changing
your recipe and it's so funny this story
about how they trying to like hype it up
like like look at this stuff softer
pillowy buns
a new and improved melted cheese that
the chain says will make you want to
savor every last bite of the rapper
yeah because the rapper and the burger
you can't even tell the difference uh
burger patties which will feature a
juicier caramelized flavor
doesn't make like what
actually
from being honest I don't think
that's where I'm going after it is y'all
like
it's just I just I don't know man
McDonald's man you just who who do y'all
think you are man
like like like I'm surprised they don't
have like a head chef that comes out you
know he's dressed in a clown outfit he's
all like yeah he's like too big on the
uh I'm going to take a mortal juicy or
the party and they're creamy out of
cheese like you we you talking about
McDonald's
we talk about McDonald's
like dude shut up man
oh man
all right in another story not fat news
but in another story this is some some
weird story for all you potheads this is
interesting and this is just about like
lack of government oversight you know
this is what I I found this to be a
really interesting story uncomfortably
high it's called testing reveals
inflated THC potency on retail cannabis
labels
why is that important so all you
potheads out there if you smoke weed and
you know you you know you buy weed look
I'm not a weed smoker but I do
I shouldn't even say that anymore I mean
I have this uh Dom pen which is like a
1-4 mix of THC uh and uh what is it CBD
so you know I have I I every now and
then for like relaxation purposes I'll
I'll smash a hit uh but it's like I
can't do like a like weed weed I just
can't
um but it's what they're talking about
in this story I'll just paraphrase for
you because you know that's that doesn't
look good on the screen but so
apparently
how you decide how much you charge for a
cannabis is based off the potency so
like the more potent the THC level is in
the in the product the more money you
can spend the more money you could
charge right so apparently there's no
real uh standardized testing for THC so
apparently you could just say whatever
you want there's no government
organization that's like okay we're
coming in to test the THC levels of this
so you know it's just like it's it feels
like a drug movie you know where the
drug dealer's like yeah cut that with
baby powder or baby formula and so you
we're not going to sell as much drugs or
like any bar that like you know sells
alcohol you know you get into like a I
don't drink alcohol but I just know from
what people say about like you know like
you you go to some bars and you're like
oh the drinks are the drinks aren't
strong at all and then you maybe go to
another bar and like you have a drink
about that big you know a little a
little shot or whatever and a little of
whatever kind of drink you know and
you're like oh wow this is like really
strong so it just depends on where you
go right and so with the with the THC so
apparently these places are inflating
their numbers feels illegal to me
so they're telling you
and it turns out from this story from
this test and you know I don't know how
accurate everything is but they're
saying
in this story that in some cases it's
like
15 to 30 percent less than what they're
saying I mean that's a lot and then
they're charging what they would so this
so apparently there's some
there's some like you know chart for oh
if it's this strong you know we're
charging this amount and it's not really
that strong but they're still charging
that amount so I don't know so you guys
really need to like if you're uh if
you're a weed smoker and you buy from a
certain place I think it's important to
ask like hey how strong is this really
in comparison and is it really that
strong because you might find that
you're probably paying you know so much
money and I get it too because it's like
what a taxed business that must be
anytime you make something like that
legal you know the chain of money is
like cut by probably like 40 maybe
because you know the government's taking
their cut the taxes on that is probably
higher uh you know now they have to like
you're not only paying rent for a place
and they're paying employees and they
gotta have a employment tax and uh all
this stuff as opposed to just like you
know what I mean selling on the street
corner uh you know with uh Nino Brown
selling out of a you know you know what
I mean selling out of an apartment
building whatever it is so
I don't know and I see somebody in the
chat saying they're setting themselves
up for a lawsuit I just don't know if
that's true because you can't like
there's no real
like how are you gonna prove it and I
don't know if you're going to be able to
like you're gonna have to buy weed from
a place
take it someplace get it tested maybe
somebody will do this maybe they maybe
there will be a lawsuit but that person
whoever does that lawsuit is they're not
going to win but they will usher in an
era where the government might have to
step in and be like okay
you know you have to charge you have to
like this is what you have to like test
it you have to put the real numbers out
like the calories in food in California
you know you know you go to a place and
there's a law California law is you have
to show the calorie content so imagine
if like they weren't showing the correct
calorie content you know but calories is
something that's easily looked up so
that's why they have to be real with it
because if you remember I don't know if
anybody if anybody can honestly remember
pre-calorie uh before they were showing
calories on stuff everything was huge
man you go to Starbucks and it'd be like
a big piece of coffee cake a big ass
scone you know and they charge whatever
they charge for it and then they had to
put the calorie content on there and
then we started to have this sort of
fake Health Consciousness right
and then like they were like they had to
put the calories and you go into this
you go into Starbucks and you're like
what
this scone is 1700 calories
it was mind-blowing and so then
Starbucks was like oh so they had to cut
everything in half they started selling
you smaller things and and offering
smaller sizes of things because the
calories was just like crazy and that
was the idea of being health conscious
so I think some kind of law like that is
going to have to be in place but this
isn't something you could just look up
and test you know what I'm saying so
they're gonna have to do it
it also reminds me of taxis I know this
is a crazy jump but
in Vegas for instance this was a thing
you get in a taxi right before and and
oh let's say you're getting a taxi like
you're at a hotel and you get in a taxi
and you say take me to the airport they
always used to say this how would you
like to go you want to take the freeway
or you want to take to because they know
they gonna take you on some ridiculous
roundabout route and you're gonna end up
paying more money like why is this a cab
ride 35 I could see the airport from
here right
Vegas passed a law
they passed this law this ordinance or
whatever you call it where it is a set
price from the airport to certain places
on the Strip let me tell you something
you get in a cab now when you go to
Vegas
that [__] is quick as hell you get right
to where you need to go and I loved it I
used to sit in a car I was I was I used
to talk so much smack
when that first happened I was like oh
yeah I look at the taxi guy oh yeah all
of a sudden y'all going right to the
thing now huh you know every taxi cab
driver would be like you know with a
look on their face like man shut up
they do it in LA now too actually this
is like
this is why
in LA
taking a taxi is cheaper than an Uber
it's a little known it's it's like a
little under the table secret I'm
telling you guys right now
if you're at the airport depending on
where you live you need to check check
the taxi first man because they're like
it's a certain they can only charge this
amount going from LA to downtown now and
so there's certain mileage things now
depending on where you live where you'll
get into a taxi like where I live
compared to the airport I'm just
speaking for me because I live I'm like
15 minutes away from the airport I live
on the west side of La so but still
sometimes I would look there would be
times especially after covet you look in
the thing and you'd be like oh man
seventy dollars it's like a 70 Uber I
get into a cab it's 19.
it's just you know and I was like uh oh
so cabs are back but then you go to
other cities like I went to what city
was I in I want to say it was Austin it
was either Austin or Dallas I think it
was it was I was in Dallas and so I
thought the same thing I got into this
cab and the cab was ex and I go why is
it so expensive
because they don't have that they could
do whatever they want so
when there's no oversight when there's
no one looking at a business like that
that's what happens so anyways to get
back to it
the weed business is such a new business
that
you know people are always going to find
a way
to like get over onto you
you know that and that's what they're
doing so I think that you know the weed
companies are out here
uh taking advantage man and so just be
on the lookout y'all you know if you're
a weed smoker be careful because they
trying to get you man
they out here trying to get you so
anyways I hope I talked about everything
that I said I was going to talk about so
make sure like I say you go check it out
somewhere in Queens the movie opens up I
believe this Friday uh is this Friday
the 24th yeah I believe the movie opens
up this week they just had a Premiere in
uh New York I couldn't go I wanted to go
but I couldn't go and Shout out again to
Ray Romano because he talked about me on
Marc maron's podcast they had a little
moment because I've told this story on
my podcast how he told me I was the
first choice but when I went into the
dressing room the clothes had a
different actor's name on them and I was
like what I thought I was the first
choice and so I went to him on set and I
was like oh I was like huh am I the
First Choice and then he just was like
dude no no it was like a New York hire a
blah blah blah but I was just teasing
you know what I mean I just thought it
was funny
and I'm a I'm an [__] right so you
know what I mean I probably shouldn't
have done that because shout out to Ray
for giving me to work and and then when
I went to the screening in La you know I
wasn't sitting on the panel because I
have a very small part but Ray was like
I want to shout out to some other actors
that are here Eric Griffin is here you
know what I mean and you know he's
actually uh he's actually a really great
dude you know I've worked with some
really great
people I've worked with some Giants man
you know to like be on Jim Carrey's show
and to like interact with him you know
what I mean like have conversations and
like you know I had these great pictures
with him when I look at those pictures
and I think about it and I go oh my God
this is Jim Carrey I have a picture with
Jim Carrey where we're head to head man
it's you know what I mean that kind of
stuff I remember I worked with Adam
Sandler just to have a scene with Adam
Sandler so to get to the dude's question
who asked me earlier to Super Chat and
thank you for the Super Chat working
with Adam Sandler was great like to do
the he's a movie making Savant he knows
every little detail of what's going on
on the set he can he knows what every
job does and he just he he just knows
how to tell a story and he's got that
thing too he's just got that thing where
he's just funny you know what I mean
he's just present and funny and genuine
but I hate him because he didn't put me
in part two
hahaha
why am I not a part two Sandler huh you
know what I mean hope that movie flops
anyway so shout out to that
and also I've worked with Tim Allen like
I've I've done Road gigs with Tim Allen
he's a great dude to be around you know
so I was like damn I'm working with Tim
Allen you know it's like yeah you know
you know what I mean I like my I like my
little career I've had you know what I
mean like my little career y'all
um all right y'all let's see uh it's
that time again let me see what beat I'm
gonna pick today
uh you know I get I I've all these great
beats man that people send
um
that people have sent me over the over
the years of doing we're from a griffin
if you're a producer and you want to
send me a beat for the right for the for
the dad stuff yeah I'm a terrible rapper
you know what I mean
but whatever it's just it's just fun
that's why I do it so you know what time
it is y'all yeah
it's that rap recap
Eric G rapping on that beat that slaps
we talk about this book
while you move your feet
[Music]
oh gotta watch
child went so
I'mma in the dope
watching him slap slap
kicking and shooting
[Music]
NBA playoffs everybody be going off
suspended Dream Home Green
that boy is lean
should the stepped on that dude
that [__] was rude
now we're back Eric G you get slapped
somewhere in Queens
go see it
you gotta be it
the rap recap
this is a rap recap
bouncing on the beat
snapping those feet
slapping those cheeks
booty pop
just shake it shaking it
Faking It
McDonald's got a new recipe
I can't wait to see
you know who I be
big old fat hairy jigs
all right y'all thanks for watching
ripping with Griffin and I'll see you
next week make sure you guys hit the
Subscribe button hit the notifications
I'll be on Twitch I'll be on Twitch
shortly so check me out there if you
want to support be a patreon member and
check me out in the Louisville Comedy
Club coming to you tomorrow so make sure
if you're in the Louisville Kentucky
area I can't wait to see you and thanks
for watching Griffin with Griffin
booty pop
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]